we are joined exclusively by the
governor of florida ron desantis
governor thank you for being here
overnight polling must have been really
bad for biden's big fascism speech given
the whiplash he gave everybody today
what was your initial reaction when you
first heard what he said
well i thought it was one of the most
disgusting speeches an american
president has ever given he ran as being
a unifier and he's basically saying to
the vast majority of the country that
disapproves of him
that they're effectively a threat to the
republic he dotters he lashes out
but at the end of the day his policies
are why there's so much opposition to
him he came in and he opened the border
and we've seen what a disaster that's
been he kneecapped american energy we've
seen how that's hurt millions and
millions of people across our country
they've inflated the currency we have
one of the worst inflations we've had in
over 40 years so of course people are
going to be upset at all the wreckage
that he's left in his wake he is the
american nero he's a failed leader and i
think that he is doing this because he's
trying to energize his base to fend off
a real butt whip in this november
governor to what do you attribute the
flip-flopping here is this senility or
is this self-preservation because he saw
the polling on this speech and the
reaction
look it's been said that the president
of the united states is whoever is
feeding his teleprompter and so they fed
that teleprompter in in philadelphia
last night and he angrily delivered that
speech and lashed out at his fellow
countrymen today he was asked off the
cuff and he said something totally
opposite but i'd note raymond they're
tweeting from his account the same nasty
stuff that he said last night and so i
think the people that are in control of
the white house
want to drive this message that people
that dissent from his policies are
somehow second-class citizens and think
about it they've been willing to
mobilize the administrative apparatus of
government to go after people they don't
like remember this time last year they
were imposing vax mandates they wanted
people to lose their job based on
getting an mrna shot or not and
unfortunately i think the weaponization
of this government is something when you
talk about 87 000 irs agents who's that
going to go after it's going to go after
the people that he was attacking in his
speech last night governor here's what
biden said about acceptable republicans
watch this
not every republican embraces their
extreme ideology
i know
because i've been able to work with
these mainstream republicans american
democracy only works
only if we choose
to respect the rule of law and the
institutions that were set up in this
chamber behind me
only if
we respect our legitimate political
differences
governor who made biden the passport
officer of mainstream republicanism and
does the governor of florida fit in that
definition do you think
well look he talks about rule of law
what has he done he's violated his oath
of office to take care that the laws are
faithfully executed by opening the
border he's not following the law there
look what he did with the student loan
bailout congress never authorized that
he's citing a law from september 11th to
somehow give loan forgiveness and put it
on the backs of the taxpayer for people
with degrees in gender studies so spare
me this idea of the rule of law he
doesn't give a darn about the rule of
law and yes the only republicans he
likes are republicans that want him to
get his way if you stand up against his
bad policies like we do in florida then
of course he's going to try to write you
out over who's acceptable as an american
citizen yeah well yeah i mean if kevin
mccarthy becomes speaker i is he an
acceptable republican or not is he not
going to speak to the speaker of the
house i rather doubt it governor last
night we saw two marines standing at
attention behind biden at least one
veterans group says they're reduced to
props here's how the white house press
secretary defended it
the presence of the marines at the
speech was intended to demonstrate the
deep and abiding respect
the president has for these services
service members
to these ideals
and the unique role our independent
military plays in defending our
democracy governor you're a veteran your
reaction to that
yeah i mean he's using those marines as
a prop for a partisan attack on half the
country
i think that that's something that is uh
doesn't sit well with a lot of veterans
i'd also say he respects veterans he
respects active duty he has kicked out
military members based on the kovid jab
that's not respect in my book we've lost
a lot of good people who wanted to serve
but for his mandates yeah well some are
saying it was also a way to underscore
his war talk if you will and they keep
saying this is not a political speech
but sure it sounded like it and the
imagery was quite aggressive like the
praetorian guard surrounding him there
yeah look and then i think you look at
the way he's weaponized federal agencies
it all plays into this idea
of him mobilizing government against
people he doesn't like and he has done
that time and time again and i think
he's going to continue to do it and if
republicans do take control they need to
hold them accountable because i think
it's likely to get worse
if he loses in the midterms governor we
knew school closings during covet were
devastating but this national test
results uh this report card shows that
the pandemic erased two decades of
progress in math and reading democrats
are now trying to blame republicans
which we'll get to a bit later in the
show but i have to ask you you took a
lot of criticism for reopening those
schools early in florida what is your
message tonight for those trying to
blame you and trump for these
educational setbacks
well first of all the pandemic didn't
cause those setbacks locked down
policies of democrat governors anthony
fauci
national teachers unions who wanted
schools closed they are the ones that
caused that in florida we said you have
a right to be in school and you need to
be in school and we've done much better
as a result but it wasn't the pandemic
because all it required was leadership
to say we need to keep kids in school
and those democrats and those unions and
the left and fouchy they chose ideology
over what was right for those kids and
the damage is going to be lasting
regardless of what fauci wants to tell
you governor before i let you go we see
the polls tightening the generic polls
moving into these uh generic ballots
moving into the midterms what would be
your advice to the republican party what
notes should they strike in these
closing days and how should they counter
what we heard from president biden last
night
well hold biden accountable this is a
referendum on his failures make sure
everybody knows how his policies have
contributed to the mess we're in and
then articulate what you will do to
address things like the border like
crime like inflation i think if you do
that i think republicans are going to
win both chambers and i think it will be
a really good night governor ron
desantis thank you for making the time
happy labor day to you and we'll talk to
you soon i hope hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else